là messieurs le bureau politique s'est
réuni il était pratiquement au grand
complet et ses travaux avaient été
préparés ce matin sous la présidence de
gérard larcher en comité politique avec
un certain nombre de responsables de
notre mouvement qui dont certains sont à
nos côtés et je les remercie le premier
point qui a été abordée après que
françois fillon est assistée ou la
première dizaine de minutes notre
réunion et remercier chacun d'entre nous
et délivrer un message d'unité pour les
élections législatives le premier point
qui a été abordé qui a d'ailleurs été le
point essentiel de ce bureau politique a
été le second tour de l'élection
présidentielle
il y a eu un très large débat où les
prises de parole ont été très nombreuses
et le texte qui a été retenu l'a été par
consensus
il s'agit d'un texte que l'on va vous
remettre mais que je vais vous lire
c'est un texte d'équilibré et qui sera
accompagné en conscience le par les
expressions ou les décisions déjà et des
autres voilà le texte
face au front national l'abstention ne
peut être un choix
nous appelons à voter contre marine le
pen pour la faire battre au second tour
de l'élection présidentielle et nous
engagerons dès demain la campagne des
législatives avec notre projet
d'alternance le seul capable de
redresser la situation de la france
[Musique]
après cette ce point sur la demande de
gérard larcher
le bureau politique a approuvé que soit
confiée à christian jacob président du
groupe des républicains à l'assemblée
nationale la mission de préparer la
direction avec nos partenaires et amis
de l'udf de la campagne législative qui
va donc s'engager
de la même façon après que le bureau
politique est adopté ce point est
approuvée ce point est toujours sur
proposition gérard larcher il a été
confié à eric woerth le soin d'ajuster
le programme des républicains qui avait
été adoptée en juin 2016 avec le
programme de françois fillon et avec nos
amis et alliés de lui des i pour que
lors de la campagne législative ce
programme soit adapté à tout ce qui a pu
être échangé ressenti entendu perçues
pendant les semaines de débats
politiques qui viennent de s'écouler
je voudrais préciser enfin que les
instances qui avaient été modifiées ou
créés après la primaire et je pense au
comité politique mais également à la
commission nationale d'investiture dont
la composition avait été très
sérieusement remanié ses instances
reviennent ce qu'elle était avant la
primaire puisque celle ci est maintenant
derrière nous et sera créée en
remplacement du comité politique un
bureau exécutif qui fonctionnera en lien
avec le bureau politique pour toutes les
affaires qui relèvent de la vie de notre
mouvement
voilà les travaux tels qu'ils ont été
tenue j'ajoute que nous aurons à
préciser dans les jours qui viennent un
certain nombre de points en particulier
que pour ceux d'entre nous qui
choisirons de voter pour monsieur
vaqueront il nous semble que participer
activement à la campagne est un élément
qui ne cadre pas avec ce que nous avons
définies et de même toute négociation
nous paraît également exclu